[Music]
on this thursday night grim
projections for canada's biggest
province the looming crisis
as deaths and hospitalizations continue
to rise
we're bending the curve a bit but we
have to do better than that plus the
pressure from the premiers on the prime
minister
the demands for more money for health
care the two michaels spend two
excruciating years locked up in china
are they any closer to freedom the hot
business
of dry ice a canadian company's vital
role in distributing the vaccine
plus they died within an hour of each
other there's not a moment i've seen
them not going together
how covid ended a lifelong love story
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the good news about a vaccine on the way
is being tempered by the reality of what
is still happening in many parts of this
country
ontario canada's biggest province has
set a new record for new covid 19 cases
in a single day
nearly 2 000 and 35 more ontarians have
died
quebec reported more than 1800 new cases
today and 33 more deaths
in alberta more than 1500 new cases were
reported
13 more albertans died bc has more than
720 new cases and 28 people died in the
past day that's a
record for bc going into the holiday
season and the new year the picture is
nothing to celebrate in ontario the
percentage of positive tests appears to
be flattening but
projections released today contain lots
of bad news
in toronto 70 percent of cases have no
epidemiological link
meaning it's not known how people got
infected and the projections
show hospitalizations including icu's
and deaths
will all keep rising the ontario
government has extended all covet 19
emergency orders until at least january
20th eric sorenson has our top story
tonight
colvit 19 has swept into this london
ontario hospital
more than 140 positive cases half among
patients
half among staff in mississauga and
toronto smaller outbreaks across a
network of three hospitals
where at least 36 staff and several
patients have tested positive
and while outbreaks are a problem in
some hospitals many
face another challenge space a hospital
network in york region has declared it's
at a tipping point in managing covet 19
volumes
across the province one month ago the
number of covid patients in hospitals
and intensive care units was manageable
since then hospitalizations have almost
doubled and the number in icu beds has
almost tripled in one month
what now you could see a rapid movement
amongst hospitals to have to start
making more beds
and so how and what that means is
basically starting to cancel elective
surgeries
the basic problem remains rising covet
19 cases
they hit 1350 per day on average last
month
worst case projections warned of 6500
cases by now
a partial circuit breaker new
restrictions in hot zones
has helped flatten the curve somewhat
but numbers have still climbed to more
than 1860 cases a day
on average 500 more than a month ago
we're bending the curve a bit where the
data shows we are
slowing the rate of increase but we have
to do better than that
that's because rising cases will lead to
still more hospitalizations
the number of icu beds in use over the
last month not only topped 200
it will stay above that threshold till
january at least
and the projection for even small
percentage increases could see demand
for icu beds approach
300 or worst case 500 icu beds
you can see how the system requires a
bit of breathing room and icu beds
in case of emergencies and what cobit
patients are doing is they're eating
into that breathing room
to the point where already there's
almost none left one hopeful development
starting next tuesday ontario will begin
administering vaccine doses
in toronto and ottawa but initially it
will amount to a trickle of protection
as covid19 cases and hospitalizations
continue to rise eric sorensen global
news toronto
the two vaccination sites in ontario
will be the ottawa hospital and the
university health network in toronto
starting on tuesday december 15th the
first doses of the pfizer biotech
vaccine
will be given to health care workers in
long-term care homes and other high-risk
places
it is no surprise that vaccines and
health care dominated discussions today
between the prime minister
and the premiers much of it comes down
to money and
there's never enough our chief political
correspondent david aiken has his ear on
these talks
david yeah really donna it just two
topics in front of the first ministers
today
they spent the morning going over
details of the vaccine rollout plan
and then after lunch the discussion got
a little more
pointed and that is how one participant
described it
as the premiers tried unsuccessfully to
get prime minister justin trudeau
to commit to giving the provinces a
combined 28
billion dollars extra next year for
health care
unfortunately despite the premier's
unanimous demand
justin trudeau refused to commit to
substantially
increase health transfer
he said that it was premature because of
the covet 19 situation to have this
discussion
we think that it's more important than
ever
now we heard the same kind of statement
from saskatchewan scott mo
ontario's doug ford but prime minister
justin trudeau said
he is ready to put more money into
canada's health care system
but he would not commit to the premier's
demand so
it looks like those pointed discussions
are going to continue donna
david quebec has said it wants the first
viol
pfizer biontech vaccines to go to
residents in long-term care homes other
provinces say that's not feasible
because
that vaccine is so tricky to keep frozen
and move around
what more have we learned about that
yeah this is really interesting and it
is something
all the provinces are grappling with
because all the provinces have put
vaccinating residents
of long-term care homes right at the top
of their vaccination priority list but
the problem is
those residents really cannot be moved
and pfizer biontech
does not recommend sending vaccination
teams
into homes exactly for the reasons you
said their vaccine requires
extra cold storage very special handling
instructions
and so provinces right now are trying to
figure out
how to do this with the pfizer biontech
vaccine
we expect that it will be able to be
broken down and transported in limited
ways
perhaps in the next couple of weeks now
the backup plan is waiting
for that moderna vaccine wait until
that's approved because
that's the vaccine that is easier to
work with and vaccination teams
could take that into long-term care
homes now
on that front premiers were told to
expect their first shipments of that
moderna vaccine
early in the new year and that's
important because it is the moderna
vaccine
that is going to be the one that goes to
the three northern territories
and to remote indigenous communities
donna
okay important information david aiken
and ottawa thanks the u.s
is poised to be the next country to
approve the pfizer biontech vaccine
an independent advisory panel of experts
spent the day reviewing data
and late today it recommended to the fda
that the vaccine
is safe and effective that means
vaccinations in the u.s could begin
almost immediately
the country is in crisis more than three
thousand americans died of covet on
wednesday
a new record for a single day and more
than one hundred and six thousand people
are in the hospital
jennifer johnson on america's final
phase on the path to a vaccine
as over 125 americans die of coven 19 an
hour
the information submitted with the
request includes
safety and efficacy data an advisory
panel to the food and drug
administration recommended emergency use
authorization
for the experimental pfizer biontech
vaccine
the fda commissioner says he has full
confidence in the group's decision
our scientists are world class they're
mothers
fathers brothers sisters grandparents
we've
also been there with the american people
and we understand the urgency
the panel was most concerned about
allergic responses to the vaccine
after at least two people with a history
of severe allergies
had serious reactions in the uk as a
precaution
officials there are recommending people
with severe allergies
not be inoculated shortly after getting
the vaccine
they developed a severe reaction and
they fortunately were able to give
themselves the epipen and got better
you know that type of reaction tends to
be very rare fda approval of the vaccine
is expected friday
the rollout will be immediate ups and
fedex trucks will leave pfizer's deep
freeze center in the midwest
and along with specially outfitted
planes deliver millions of doses to
every part of the country
we are still operating at historically
remarkable speeds i think we do have
huge challenges ahead here in the united
states
in distributing the vaccine
could begin this weekend the trump
administration's operation warp speed
plans to have 20 million americans
vaccinated by the end of december
health care workers and nursing home
residents will be first
personally i cannot roll up my sleeve
fast enough to get this vaccination and
i guess i would urge the community when
it's that time to do the same
in the early part of 2021 federal health
officials believe their biggest
challenge
will be convincing most americans the
vaccine is safe
and getting them to show up for both
doses of the pfizer biontech vaccine
jennifer johnson global news washington
the modern vaccine we mentioned also in
the pipeline for
approval in canada is now in clinical
trials involving children
and adolescents the trial in the u.s
plans to enroll 3 000 healthy people
between the ages of 12 and 17.
each participant would receive either a
placebo or the vaccine in two doses 28
days apart moderna hopes to have enough
data on the safety and efficacy of the
vaccine to allow it to be given to 12 to
17 year olds before they head back to
school in the fall of 2021.
pfizer biontech began vaccine trials on
children in october
and canada has pre-ordered tens of
millions of doses of
both vaccines from moderna and pfizer
biontech
all elementary and secondary schools in
windsor ontario and
surrounding essex county will close on
monday because of a rapid rise in
covid19 cases there
students will go to online learning and
schools will remain open to teachers and
staff
full-time daycares operating within
schools will also be allowed to open
the order will be in place until
december 18th when students go
on break but it could be extended beyond
the christmas break
today the region reported more than 100
new cases for the second day in a row
a team of specialized paramedics is
helping deal with a surge in covid19
cases in a community in northern british
columbia
yesterday a rapid response team arrived
in fort st james it's a small rural
community about 11 hours north of
vancouver
the team is expected to stay there for
several days it's the first time this
highly trained paramedic team has been
deployed
there are at least 40 active cases of
covid19
in the region two canadians have endured
the entire pandemic imprisoned in china
accused without any evidence of
espionage and today marks a grim
anniversary for them
michael kovrig and michael spavor have
been held for two years now kept in
separate prisons
largely cut off from the world for
months they weren't even allowed
visits from canadian consular officials
there was some confusion today when a
chinese foreign ministry spokesman said
they'd been indicted and tried the
canadian government said
that official misspoke there has been no
trial
and there appears to be no progress in
efforts to bring them home
michael couture reports for two men who
have been through
so much michael kovrig and michael
spavor
are said to be in good shape and good
spirits according to canada's ambassador
to
china dominic barton has had virtual
visits with the two men in their
respective jails
speaking to them via video conference
government's wife
vina najibullah says michael is keeping
up a strict
exercise regiment and reading
philosophical books to keep his mind
strong oh yeah i've sent a few shipments
of books
spravor's friend john dunbar has also
been sending a steady supply of reading
material
he's known spavor since 2006 as a
gregarious
guy caught up in a diplomatic dispute
i have faith that if anybody can
survive this and come out of it still
able to smile it will be him
spavor and kovrig's detention is widely
seen as retaliation for the arrest
of huawei cfo mong wang zhou on a u.s
extradition request
but after two years there's been little
movement the release
of these two brave canadians is an
absolute priority for
our government canada has long called
the two michael's arrests arbitrary
the government has recently taken a
stronger stance calling it
coercive diplomacy that's still not
enough
for the opposition leader we have to
show that we're willing to stand up for
our interests our citizens and our
values
sometimes with tough and difficult
decisions like sanctions
canada's approach has been to rally
international partners to pressure china
his former diplomat says canada needs to
do more
hoping that if we treat the chinese
regime
with extreme tolerance
that they will see their way clear to
doing the right thing
and releasing culverican's favor has not
worked
the u.s could help if mung agrees to a
deferred prosecution agreement
talks between her lawyers and the u.s
justice department are reportedly
underway
and some believe that could open the
door to china releasing spavor
and kovrig donna
mike lacature in ottawa thanks new
charges in the beirut blast coming up
the accusations against lebanon's
prime minister
more charges have been laid in
connection with that deadly explosion at
the port in beirut
lebanon's caretaker prime minister
hassan diab and three former cabinet
ministers
are now facing negligence charges
they're the most senior people to be
indicted
more than 200 people in beirut were
killed thousands more were injured in
the explosion in august
it was caused by the ignition of a large
stockpile of explosive material
that had been unsafely stored at the
port for years
there's more grim news about those
millions of culled mink in denmark
they may be contaminating the
groundwater 17 million mink were called
in early november
after a cluster of clove coven 19
mutations were identified in the animals
and in workers
now there's a risk that groundwater
below the two meter pits
will seep into nearby streams lakes and
reservoirs
geophysical probes are being done to
assess the environmental impact
keeping it cool still ahead the bc
company that's helping the vaccine
stay on ice
[Music]
you're watching global national
a relatively new canadian company is
preparing for its biggest likely most
important contract
ever it's been hired by the government
to provide dry ice to transport the
pfizer biontech coronavirus vaccine
because as paul johnson explains dry ice
is now a hot commodity
so this is one of our dry ice bins that
we use at fraser valley dry ice here
meet one of canada's newly crowned kings
of the cold
we saw an opportunity that we could
manufacture dry
ice on demand for our customers at a
competitive price
paul thompson and his business partner
started the fraser valley dry
ice company early this year with the
intention of supplying the food packing
business
an astute move given the big farming
economy near their abbotsford bc
facility
then the world changed
while the arrival of an effective
vaccine in a matter of months
has been an historic achievement there's
still a major challenge
distribution complicated by the pfizer
biontech
vaccines need to be stored at minus 70
degrees celsius
luckily for western canadians this new
dry ice factory
had just come online this machine is
pretty high tech um
most of the productions that we do with
it are basically
as easy as a touch of a button dry ice
is made entirely
out of the gas carbon dioxide it's one
of the most plentiful compounds
on planet earth and it's turned into a
solid through the process known as
deposition
very useful for keeping frozen foods
cool
shipping our new vaccine or making
awesome fog
for a heavy metal ship
churning out the pellet-sized pieces
that are ideal for storing
and shipping the new vaccine thompson is
confident
their machine can meet all the needs of
their new contract with the federal
government
they're ready to ship at a moment's
notice if still a bit surprised by the
speed
that this new business model appears we
feel very excited we're very happy that
we get to be a part of the solution
paul johnson global news abbotsford bc
a husband and wife lost to covid19
within hours
next one bc family's tragedy
more than thirteen thousand canadians
have died this year of covid19
and beneath that big number are so many
individual stories of lives lived
and families left to grieve tonight we
have one of those stories
a husband and wife in bc who spent their
lives together
and who died within hours of each other
sarah mcdonald reports
you can see how beautiful my mom was in
their nearly 70 years of marriage
pasnali and shel sultan remtula were
inseparable
there's not a moment i've seen them not
going together it was a true love
like a true soulmate's true love so to
their adult children
it was devastating but not exactly
surprising the pair died within
hours of each other on sunday both in
separate hospitals
both having somehow contracted covet 19.
i could not bear it i was totally blank
like i don't know what to do
first al-karim ramtullah's mother passed
her heart failed it was like
heartbreaking it also felt like she
actually
was with me telling that i'm also gonna
take my dad
your dad with me and then his father
less than two hours later
having never learned his wife was gone
but his children think
he somehow knew i started saying my
prayers and within 10 minutes they
passed away
their deaths marking a sad and sudden
ending to a remarkable love story
spanning seven decades and two
continents the remtulas still
well known and highly respected in
zanzibar and tanzania for dedicating
their lives to public
and community service a legacy that
continued in canada
he was more interested that the family
should be here he was always telling me
that if you want to see heaven that's
heaven
with both his parents abruptly gone
their eldest son now feels it's his duty
to share their story
and a warning that bears repeating
please please
protect yourself protect your elders are
the most precious thing
his may no longer be here but his wishes
in death
his parents might save lives his message
wear a mask and do everything in your
power to protect the most vulnerable
among us i'm going through a hard time
but in the same time i
feel like i'm so blessed that i was
there with them
till to the last breath and i'm so
blessed to have parents like that
we had the best mom and dad sarah
mcdonald global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight is the start of hanukkah the
jewish festival of lights and people are
finding creative ways to celebrate this
year
a synagogue in ottawa is having a
drive-in hanukkah light show
the message of this celebration is that
a little light dispels a lot of darkness
certainly a message we can all use this
year happy hanukkah to all of you who
are celebrating
and thanks for watching robin gill will
be here tomorrow and i'll see you on
saturday for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]